saviez-vous qu avant d'être française la
course était italienne jusqu'à la
deuxième moitié du xviiie siècle dans
corse france toute une histoire
dominique lanzalavi revient sur plus de
deux siècles de relations houleuses
entre paris et les corses plusieurs
grandes figures ont joué un rôle majeur
les historiens retiennent notamment
napoléon iii celui qui a achevé la
francisation de la corse dès l'année
1853 il imposera l'enseignement du
français dans les écoles de corps et en
1858 l'italien sera interdite la langue
française comme grand facteur
d'intégration de la corse mais est-ce
que ça a suffi l'histoire nous montre
que non les corses se sont plusieurs
fois senti trahi par paris lors de la
première guerre mondiale par exemple les
sujets de tension entre paris et les
corses il y en aura d'autres ce
sentiment corse d'être la dernière roue
du carrosse d'être délaissée méprisés ou
abandonner le réalisateur insiste
beaucoup là dessus une des thèses du
film sans jamais justifié les actions
violentes bien sûr c'est tout de même de
dire que l'état français a pu être
injuste et maladroit quelques
responsables politiques cependant se
sont démarqués et ont essayé de
comprendre la spécificité corse comme
lionel jospin qui a ressenti stupeur et
dégoût après l'assassinât du préfet
erignac mais l'ancien premier ministre a
accepté de parler avec tout le monde je
ne vois pas comment démocratiquement ou
légitimement on aurait pu exclure de ces
discussions des élus légitimes de
l'accord ge parce que leurs options
politiques ou leurs opinions étaient
favorables à l'indépendance corse france
toute une histoire à voir ce samedi sur
public sénat vous le retrouverez ensuite
en replay sur notre chaîne youtube et
surtout plateforme